[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing grindelwald
and which house he would have been in
had he attended hogwarts
what prompted this video was some of the
comments on the top 5 most powerful
slytherins video
i kept seeing people say where's
grindelwald and
why not grindelwald well here's why
grindelwald didn't go to hogwarts we
first see grindelwald in the deathly
hallows
when a then much older grindelwald
refused to give voldemort the
information that he needed
regarding the elder wand then we see him
again when he is much younger
and fantastic be somewhere to find them
followed by fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald for those who
aren't aware grindelwald is
the dark wizard of his time preceding
voldemort as the quintessential
dark presence in the world intent on
challenging all notions of light
and embracing all aspects of darkness he
is considered by many to be voldemort's
equal
as one of the darkest and most powerful
wizards of all time
though i am excited to see his full
display of power in the upcoming
fantastic piece films
grindelwald was born in the year 1883
and in his younger years
he didn't attend hogwarts he was
actually a student at durmstrang
institute
durmstrang like hogwarts is a school for
young witches and wizards
however the school is known to have a
bit of a dubious reputation
as they place a lot of emphasis on
teaching the dark arts
we know durmstrang from the harry potter
books and films because they competed
against hogwarts
in the tri-wizard tournament the school
was founded in the middle ages by the
great bulgarian which
narida volkanova who served as the
initial headmaster of the school
she was succeeded after her mysterious
death by professor harfang munter
who established durmstrang's reputation
for emphasizing martial magic
as an impressive part of its curriculum
it's known that the school does not
admit
muggleborns which paired with their
teachings of the dark arts
makes for the perfect breeding ground of
intolerant supremacists
grindelwald was admitted to the school
sometime in the late 1880s
or early 1890s and while he went there
he demonstrated exceptional magical
ability
however his sadistic nature also shone
through while the school was a known
proponent of the dark arts
grindelwald's experiments proved too
dark in nature and he was expelled for
them
this really says something about how
twisted his magical escapades must have
been
before he left the school he was careful
to carve the cooling card of his
obsession
the mark of the deathly hallows onto the
wall of the school
despite being expelled grindelwald was
the most talented student the durmstrang
ever produced
after being expelled grindelwald was
intent on achieving higher and higher
levels of power
this mission for power eventually landed
him in godric's hollow
england grindelwald initially traveled
to godric's hollow because it was where
ignotus peverell
the first owner of the cloak of
invisibility had been laid to rest
he thought that godric's hollow could be
a good start in his ultimate goal of
achieving immense levels of power
it was during this time that he first
met albus dumbledore
so grindelwald never went to hogwarts
but if
he had which house would he be in you
can probably guess the answer
but i'm going to explain why hogwarts
was founded in the year 990 a.d
by founders helga hufflepuff salazar
southern
gryffindor and rowena ravenclaw after
founding the school
the four founders enchanted a hat a hat
which would assign students to their
hogwarts houses
based on how closely they resembled one
of the four founders
among other things gryffindor valued
bravery ravenclaw valued intelligence
hufflepuff valued hard work and southern
valued ambition
though grindelwald fits all of these
categories quite well he definitely
slots into one
more than the others and i feel that he
would have made for an excellent
slytherin student
if ambition is a pivotal trait for
slytherin house then grindelwald is a
better fit than anyone
grindelwald's life goal was to find the
deathly hallows then lead a wizarding
revolution that would effectively put an
end to the international statute of
secrecy breaking down the secretive
divide
between the two worlds this revolution
would create a global power hierarchy
that would place powerful witches and
wizards at the top of the food chain
effectively giving them full control of
muggles and muggle affairs
if breaking down the divide between
wizarding and muggle worlds isn't
ambitious
then i don't know what is furthermore in
addition to being ambitious
slytherins tend to be shrewd cunning
strong leaders
and achievement oriented these
descriptors all fit grinder world
perfectly
grindelwald was a calculated cunning
gifted strong leader that
if it weren't for albus dumbledore would
have likely been successful
in his endeavors and that's it for this
video what do you guys think
what house would you place grindelwald
in do you have any arguments for
why he would be a better fit in another
house let me know in the comment section
below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live
you